tereza não caiu para a linha de um
branquinho e aí galera que aceite meu
canal tudo bom você e como está tudo
muito bem graças a deus a ótima eu
estava assistindo no youtube esses dias
no youtube que é o site que não faço
vídeos eu vi o vídeo do menina que fala
português é loirinha e é legal mas
porque ela mora na finlândia não ser um
país fala um negócio estranho ela fez um
vídeo falando português porque pra eles
português é difícil pra carai mas aqui a
gente estuda inglês então não sabem ler
mas quando assisto inglês nas escolas
saibam o verbo to be nós sabe responder
qual é a cor que mais gosta o assessor
foi hope chega já a boca pink então a
gente tem noção que resolvi fazer um
vídeo eu quero falar uma língua que a
gente é difícil falar qual é japonês vou
ter que entrar no todo do corpo do
google mesmo bom dia e 8 itatí vamos lá
fumar difícil eu estou com muita fome
não tomar um toco foram eu quero comer
ao que lhe como é carne como é carne
carne único o único nem eu quero comer
carne não me de leite e carne
eu quero comer ovo é ou é esse que é o
ovo tamago após que quando passa dieta é
só o vuk bom como ele está bem maguey
pois é a porta na dieta pois ela começou
a ouvir e saber do meu novo look to
tamago eu quero comer picolé
assim é a isso que a dilma tá bom
concluímos que no japão eu morrer de
fome quer que eu vou com menos na
posição conseguiu um ovo eu quero comer
um com um é cara tive por favor pode me
dizer onde fica o restaurante pode me
dizer onde come capim que podia arrastar
o dia todo esse negócio aqui é isso aqui
pra comer capim e eu não conseguia ser
uma vaca no japão a tepco é campeão
usa o tablet do por nomear o ca ao chefe
acusa o tabet do curu área o que eu
estava aqui mas isso não acarrete tucura
e aracruz sheik ohtake março e massa
neymax naruto dragon ball z
chorando o borussia e tom dourado embora
o set-top o digital ashiru bom dia e
companhia só e tati tokai caixa do caixa
quantia galera do sbt está começando
mais um e com priscilla alcântara aí que
mais gostou no japão e eu estou é sem
dinheiro pra pegar um táxi
então a gente vai pedir um táxi né ou
falar da [ __ ] pode me dar dinheiro
[Música]
não não nem roubada no japão perdeu
playboy
aretha chega a 40 prêmio da china
oriental china aparenta playboy chega a
40 perigo e por aí vai investir na área
chega a 40 playboy por empoli bueno nem
consiga faltar primeiro que você fala
japonês segundo se eu conseguisse falar
já poderia começar na memória quem diga
respeito assaltante sorridente
eu vim do piauí
lá no corolla japão é legal ele como é
que é
aqui é tudo meio no caso o cara tem de
dormir eu digo botasse la piel e cara de
artista que macho tatarak machista ou a
taxa o happy hour em karak machista
tachou a peão e cara que me ajuda aí pra
você que está no japão é é um estado
aqui do brasil onde o rio nasce uma taxa
o happy hour em karachi mágica
eu falei que sim é fértil saber o que
tem aqui o darpa o guarda-chuva piauí
ficar aqui mas também achou a pele ficar
aqui machista é enviar os currículos
agora o cara segundo grau completo tas
ou fluente em portugueses japonês você
colocar o instagram agora fluente em
japonês
os caras atacar um dom um reboquista no
instagram brasília singer a desgraça é a
10 e quando vou botar corrente japonês
não é só falar japonês e flamengo é o
meu forte é japonês a baixa foi o de
traduzir na ar o tubo sbt passar chile
gol mas não sabe a escola fica falando
vai tomar no cu um sabe a sua ficar
falando o caco já está famoso carro
tá engasgado é notável o carro
o cartão já está formado né se você
gostou desse vídeo e gostei aqui no
youtube
volta lá no facebook isso é muito
importante está muito jeito aqui nesse
vídeo no youtube porque vê o lado
facebook ou postagens consecutivo a
postar no facebook que o facebook vai
sempre ficar tive anos que ele está e
para não perder os vídeos no youtube é
só se inscrever no canal marca seu nome
que cada japonês lá no facebook onde só
fala japonês o que quer aprender a falar
japonês e aqui no youtube eu quero que
você comente aqui embaixo outra língua
que você acha bem difícil de falar pra
fazer um outro vídeo estão junto abraça
todo brasileiro que mora lá no japão ou
na china ou em qualquer lugar do mundo
obrigado eu estava assistindo tamo junto
beijam
valeu é nóis fumo na mensagem aqui óbvio
jardim robótico tineke é tomar no cu
valeu